we took drinks great painstaking care to
make sure that this communiqué and
evasion and the theme and the the real
feel and look as a movie so our movie
steel spare change it was great I you
know those intimate crowds there's
something I felt different in our
premiere with like 500 people like I
actually felt like I really watched it
for the first time tonight and as a
filmmaker I think filmmakers can relate
to this you've seen your movie so much
while you're cutting it now it has its
premiere and you feel one way you have a
certain crowd there in my thumb you may
have a perception of your movie and how
it was received and then this is our
second time here in LA now instead of
New York smaller group intimate group
the feel was totally different i watch
the movie differently and I actually the
process is story differently that's
really weird you know it makes me think
about art and how it can be interpreted
different ways it's by the energy in a
room a dealer you know where the types
of people that are there or how they're
reacting to things I said that might be
different now the last time so it was
very eye-opening to me you know and then
I think about well when your film
screening all over the country and like
people in the South that audience
we totally different it somebody in
Michigan you know what I mean so it's a
beautiful thing to share heart and just
let the audience tell you what they felt
film courage is great i love them
they're like family and we've just been
treated so well here in Los Angeles and
now it's time to go back to New York
City and fight the routes in the subway
you know and try to make another movie
somehow so I want to thank Karen word
David granted film courage downtown
independent la talk radio has just been
an amazing week smart one supposed to
cry
bye